démanteler toutes les structures d'
influence pro-russe c'est l'objectif
annoncé par le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky une sortie en
réaction notamment aux accusations du
royaume uni londres affirme que moscou
cherche à instaurer un gouvernement à sa
botte en ukraine l'ancien député
ukrainien et jenny morayef est citée par
le royaume uni comme candidats
potentiels
des accusations démenties par moscou et
par l'intéressé lui-même qui pointe du
doigt une dénonciation kafkaïenne
tout ceci est drôle et ridicule d'abord
c'est sans fondement comme tout ce qui
est annoncé par la grande bretagne
deuxièmement c'est absurde quand je suis
sous sanction de la fédération de russie
depuis le 1er novembre 2018 m'a refusé
l'entrée en russie parce que je
représente une menace pour la sécurité
russe
le vice premier ministre britannique a
de son côté réitéré les mises en garde à
l'encontre de la russie
de la communauté internationale les
européens les alliés de l'otan les états
unis nous restons solidaires pour qu'ils
aient de sérieuses conséquences si la
russie tendant vers l'ukraine mais aussi
si elle tangue installe un gouvernement
de marionnettes avec le maintien de la
pression militaire russe à ses
frontières kiev tente d'accélérer la
cadence du rapprochement avec l'occident
c'est à l'otan et à l'europe de décider
si nous ferons partie de la famille mais
c'est ce que nous voulons c'est pour
cela que nous avons souffert toutes ces
années la maison blanche s'est dite
extrêmement préoccupée à la suite des
accusations britanniques
les discussions entre washington et
moscou doivent se poursuivre dans les
prochains jours